this is the Dave Ramsey show we're glad
you're with us America thank you for
joining us I'm talking with heading into
the break I was talking with Sharon in
Sarasota Florida and 68 years old 20
years ago they bought a universal life
policy which is a type of cash value
policy a portion of your premium folks
when you have a universal policy goes to
pay the insurance cost and the insurance
is cost goes up every single year
because it's based on annual renewable
term rates and so more and more is going
to insurance cost as the policy gets
older less and less is going to the
investment to the point that they cross
the line a few years ago and contacted
Sharon and her husband and said oh now
the premium that you're paying 100
percent of it won't cover the insurance
cost so now if you want to keep the
insurance not only is 0 going to
investments but now even more has to be
paid to keep the insurance active and
that's how far we got in the discussion
is what I just said all correct Sharon
yes okay and what is the face amount of
this policy 80,000 80,000 dollars and
how much money do you all have how much
money do we have how much here in your
401ks and your now we do have retirement
accounts a total 84,000 we have a
$10,000 emergency fund we are debt free
or have to pay for good so this is kind
of like so you don't have how much is
how much cash value is in this right now
it's at 6,000 okay so and do you have
pension plans as well no okay and so
you're living on Social Security and
$80,000 or the 401k my husband still
works this guy he has 36 thousand in
income and he brings in 21,000 in Social
Security okay and I don't look gotcha in
the face amount of this policy you said
was $80,000 yeah okay we did look into
term insurance for him but number one
it's really a lot more expensive at his
age but number two he says
I'll cancer a couple times yeah
non-hodgkins lymphoma and so basically
nobody will touch it yeah very difficult
very difficult we don't know we can
lower the death benefit so what is the
premium how much is it a year how much
77 a month yeah okay all right so eight
hundred a year and you make $36,000 a
year well here's that here's the
equation here's the way it works in your
mind okay the purpose of this is to give
you an extra $80,000 if he dies before
you do okay and so is that worth 800
bucks at this stage it's there's no
investment value whatsoever so we're not
gonna the only question is you know you
you don't have a huge nest egg you've
got a small nest egg and so to double it
basically if he were to die would be
very helpful mm-hmm and so keeping the
insurance sounds really good with that
in mind you know they told us it would
only last another three or four years
anyway only 71 or 72 okay and they're
gonna make you stop anyway they're gonna
pull the plug on oh okay and at that
point you would cash it out and whatever
cash value is in there my husband would
like to get it out now yeah all right
get it out no way to get out now it's
closed the policy down right which means
that you would you know if he passes
away you'd have the 401k money the paid
for house and be living on Social
Security right yeah but you probably can
make it cuz I got a feeling you guys are
frugal people oh yeah so you probably
could make it on that but it's not going
to be a dream come true so they have
given you notice that at 62 or I'm sorry
73 or whatever so many years old they're
gonna shut the policy down regardless
yeah well well no I guess if we can keep
paying you know that's the point it
would be over two hundred a month yeah I
think we could keep it going but okay or
we could lower the death benefit
and keep it going they told us we could
do that which is what I wanted to do but
he wanted to cash it out so so we're
doing nothing yeah there's not a great
answer okay that's why I'm him and
hauling a little bit I'm trying to think
through it my tendency is at eight
hundred bucks a year right now to keep
it for a while okay
seventy seven dollars a month even if
you use the cash values you can have the
cash values to begin to pay the premium
and do you know it's going to do it's
going to use up some of that eight
thousand dollars I'm probably going to
do that and let the eight thousand
dollars pay the premiums starting today
and I'm probably going to leave it in
place a couple of years when it starts
being two hundred a month instead of
seventy seven a month at that point I'm
probably going to join his tribe and say
let's cash it out and close it down but
I don't think it's gonna make sense to
keep this long for a long long time I'm
probably gonna keep it a couple more
years how's his health what's that how
is his health well he's the first time I
went through he stayed cancer-free for
five years and this time he has been
cancer-free for two years do it so I
mean he goes in and gets scans every
every six month or so to make sure it's
not coming back so they can stay
aggressive with it good good I'm glad to
hear that well yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
let the cash value pay the premiums for
the next two years and keep it open
if and I'm gonna check on his health at
that time let's say that he's got
another episode with cancer going at
that time then you pay the premium no
matter what it costs and you keep it
open if he if he's Dean if the cancer
has come back at any stage right you
keep you keep the thing open at that
point but if he's doing really really
good and everything's clean and two
years from now you haven't seen a spot
nothing's no problems anywhere I'm
probably dropping it at that point okay
that make sense to me he wouldn't he
wouldn't be insured so yeah you know but
um but but you're also not paying you
know three thousand two thousand dollars
a year which is what it's going to be at
that point
which is starting to be ridiculous with
that kind of money you could throw money
into investments and start having some
money and but but at this stage I'm I'm
hesitant to cancel it it's it's
obviously a bad policy it's obviously
been a bad thing but it's your only
option you're stuck with it yes no that
makes it hard to discuss and hard to
think about but I'm gonna hold it two
years like the cash value pay it at the
end of that time if he's healthy and
still cancer-free I'm dropping it
otherwise I'm gonna keep it if he's got
a health issue at that time so good
question thank you for calling in and
I'm sorry you had this problem folks you
hear me yell and scream about cash value
life insurance whole life life insurance
universal life variable life is a ripoff
you just experienced it you just
experienced the back end what happens if
you buy one of those pieces of crap
policy and you're 68 years old this is
what happens because the money they put
into that stupid butt policy would be
300 grand right now in mutual funds if
they did put it into that into a good
investment instead of getting ripped off
by this insurance company and if she was
sitting there with 300 grand plus the
other 401k they'd have about four
hundred thousand bucks plus their house
is paid for
she wouldn't even have called me but
instead guess who's fat and sassy
instead of her the insurance company so
when your whole life agent says I don't
really agree with Dave Ramsey because
your whole life agents trying to rip you
off that's why your whole life agents
saying that and there's only two kinds
of whole life agents ignorant and
crooked because if you understand these
numbers and that story right there and
then you still sell this stuff that
makes you crooked you ought to be
ashamed of yourself and if you don't
understand these numbers and you're
still selling that stuff that makes you
ignorant and you shouldn't be selling
this stuff and by the way folks in case
you didn't know
you'll get screwed and what way more
often by an enthusiastic ignoramus
then you will buy a con-artist so most
of people out there selling this crap
are enthusiastic ignoramuses they're not
actual con artists
my uncle Charlie sold me this region
enthusiastic ignoramus
that's all uncle Charlie we just nailed
him right there because he's probably
not a crook if he'd actually sat down
looked and realized that sharing your if
your friend if Sharon's friends sold her
that he's not a friend my friends like
that you don't need enemies you know she
could've had 300 grand and mutual funds
easy for them what they've dumped into
this crappy product whole life life
insurance the payday lender of the
middle class I agree veyts me this is
the Dave Ramsey show